madame monsieur bonsoir le spectre de la
guerre civile dans les territoires
autonomes palestiniens à gaza la police
palestinienne a tiré sur des intégristes
il ya au moins 13 morts et 200 blessés
en france la création d'un délit pour
les grands excès de vitesse les députés
viennent d'adopter le projet de loi en
le modifiant toutefois la première
confrontation de jacques médecin avec la
justice française depuis son retour du
rugby
un conseil municipal houleux en ce
moment même à grenoble l'ouverture du
congrès du parti socialiste dans le pas
de calais et puis un invité prestigieux
sur ce plateau l'une des plus grandes
popstars actuelle sting
bonsoir bonsoir dans le dernier album
revient sur dix années de chansons que
nous évoquerons avec lui à la fin de ce
jour n'est jamais depuis l'installation
d'une police palestinienne il y a 6 mois
la bande de gaza n'avait connu un tel
carnage ce matin jour de prière les
policiers ont échangé des coups de feu
devant la mosquée avec des intégristes
des affrontements entre palestiniens qui
font craindre le début d'une véritable
guerre civile
nos correspondants charles enderlin est
talal abou rahmeh se trouvait devant la
mosquée lorsque la fusillade a commencé
les policiers palestiniens saisissent la
sono du tram à l'incident mais le clown
des militants attaquent les forces de
l'ordre qui tirent en l'air
sur la pluie on y meurt rhône les
blessés gaz a explosé
les policiers palestiniens n'ont ni gaz
lacrymogènes ni canons à eau ni balles
en caoutchouc il tire uniquement à
balles réelles
le bilan s'alourdit de minute en minute
les affrontements font rage lui gaz a
repris son aspect des pires journées de
l'ifab a complètement contre israël mais
cette fois ce sont des palestiniens qui
pierre sur d'autres palestiniens
une confrontation d'ennuyeux sec qui
sera le vainqueur
des dizaines de jeunes manifestants sont
arrêtés et parfois même dans les
ambulances csn scandalise même la
population qui ne soutient pas leur
annonce un peu partout dans la ville des
véhicules de la police palestinienne
sont attaqués par les islamistes
les manifestations spontanées s'organise
au cri d' allah akbar dieu est grand et
policiers collabos policiers traitent
près de l'hôpital shifa le médine
annonce et c'est faux que des forces
israéliennes combattent aux côtés
d'arafat dans le quartier de sarria la
foule se dirige vers l'endroit en
scandant allah ta de traîtres arafat
frère en fin d'après-midi les
accrochages se poursuivent
ici aux abords de l'hôpital chifa est
dans le centre de la ville de gaza à
proximité de la prison centrale
la police palestinienne a ouvert le feu
à plusieurs reprises sur des
journalistes
je vous rappelle le dernier bilan dont
nous disposons à l'heure actuelle donc
13 morts et au moins 200 blessés
les terribles caprices de la tempête
gordon elle a fait plus de 500 morts en
haïti ont pensé qu'elle s'était affaibli
en entrant aux états unis
mais gordon a repris du souffle et
menace maintenant l'état de caroline du
nord
patrice romney et pourtant l'oeil de
l'ouragan se trouve à 150 km au large
mais déjà le long des côtes de la
caroline du nord ces maisons que gifle
l'océan titube s'affaisse disparaissent
ivre de rafale ivre d'un vent qui
souffle à 140 kilomètres par heure bien
soir quand on est allé se coucher il y
avait encore cinq maisons là il soit n y
en a plus qu'une et personne ne veut y
mettre les pieds
car nul ne connaît les intentions de
gordon par s'effacer si l'ouragan
surprend les spécialistes il change de
direction il revient en arrière il
redouble de violence sans crier gare
en passant par les caraïbes gordon a tué
cinq cent cinquante personnes aux états
unis
le bilan est pour l'heure de six morts
et d'une quarantaine de blessés sans
oublier les dégâts facture de 100
millions de dollars
mais d'un océan de malheurs émerge
toujours un îlot de bonheur à bord de ce
bateau qui fait cap sur la colombie 3
adultes surpris par gordon mois le père
la mère la fille hélitreuillée alain
trois adultes disions-nous et un enfant
il est né à bord il n'est pas sûr que
ses parents le baptise gordon en france
maintenant quelques heures avant les
départs en week-end attention aux grands
excès de vitesse sur les routes il
constitue désormais un délit mais les
députés ont modifié le texte initial en
l'adoptant cet après midi plus sévère
avec les chauffards en ville moins
sévère avec les chauffards sur les
autoroutes et une amende maximale qui a
été diminuée de moitié
les détails du projet avec laurent
bailly pourquoi toujours plus de mesures
répressives sanctionné sur autoroute
quelqu'un qui roule à 190 2 195
kilomètres à l'heure paraît tout à fait
logique
et si les sanctions sont les mêmes
uniformes pour des fautes que je
qualifierais les unes de véniel les
autres deux mortels je crains que cette
loi au but louable ne vous donne pas de
résultat comme prévu le débat à
l'assemblée sur le renforcement des
sanctions pour les excès de vitesse a
été animée les députés ont finalement
adopté le projet bosson mais avec des
modifications
le très grand excès de vitesse sera bien
considéré comme un délit alors si on
roule à 40 km au dessus de la vitesse
autorisée en ville ou si ce dépassement
atteint 50 à l'heure sur route 60 sur
autoroute on sera bon pour le tribunal
correctionnel l'amande qui était de 15
mille francs dans le projet bosson a été
ramené par les députés à 7500 francs
quant au permis il sera bien amputé de
moitié moins six points
cette mesure dans l'aspect répressif
concerne très peu de conducteurs est là
pour dissuader dissuasion le mot est
lâché
la peur du radar va sans doute inciter à
lever le pied mais chez les
automobilistes
les avis sont partagés
un accident baba on nous dicte notre
conduite on dit fait comme ça comme ça
comme ça alors que façon c'est pour sa
vie qu'on jouait à chacun son point de
vue mais très bientôt
nulle automobilistes ne sera censé
ignorer la loi besson
toute la journée un peu partout en
france la colère des surveillants de
prison ils ont joué au chat et à la
souris avec les compagnies de crs leur
détermination semble intacte après
plusieurs jours de grève dans les
équipes dans les établissements
pénitentiaires pardon aujourd'hui ils
n'ont laissé entrer que les familles des
détenus
eric lemasson et gilles de blair durcir
le mouvement
c'était la consigne ici à loos les lille
comme ailleurs les surveillants avaient
décidé d'empêcher les intervenants
extérieurs avocats
le visiteur de prison d'entrer à la
maison d'arrêt bousculade l'entrée avait
été dégagée par les forces de l'ordre
jusqu'au prochain pic et jusqu'au
prochain face à face même consigne à la
prison de la santé à paris
un piquet de surveillants à l'entrée et
des chauffeurs livreurs qui en font les
prêts ce matin et cet après-midi
impossible pourtant après 11 jours de
grogne de manif de tentatives de
blocages des mouvements des détenus
l'administration pénitentiaire continue
de fonctionner les forces de l'ordre
font le ménage et les camions
transportant les détenus finissent
toujours par an très difficile alors
pour les surveillants qui n'ont pas le
droit de grève de faire comprendre à
l'opinion leurs revendications notamment
celle des effectifs
les équipes i tout le monde connaît
lorsqu'il ya des évasions dans les
prisons tout le monde condamne quand on
n'arrive pas à faire notre travail tous
les jours protidiet mans on nous visent
et on montre du doigt pour telle ou
telle région pour tel ou tel problème
dans les prisons françaises c'est un
manque crucial de personnel ce soir à
fleury mérogis comme hier soir et comme
avant-hier les surveillants se réuniront
pour un nouveau face à face avec les
gendarmes moment des barricades et comme
hier soir comme avant-hier un passage en
force pour faire entrer les détenus à la
maison d'arrêt le ministère a fait un
geste en débloquant quelques postes
supplémentaires mais les surveillants se
dit déterminée a entamé lundi leur
troisième semaine de mobilisation
l'un des seuls établissements ne pas
être en grève et c'est la prison modèle
et moderne de saint quentin fallavier
dans l'isère où depuis hier jacques
médecin est incarcéré mais les juges de
grenoble n'ont pas traîné dès ce matin
ils ont reçu l'ancien maire de nice et
lui ont signifié une double mise en
examen à grenoble serge m'endors il
était 8 heures ce matin lorsque dans ce
fourreau jacques médecin a quitté la
prison de saint-quentin-fallavier près
de lyon convoi a parcouru 70 kilomètres
avant d'arriver au palais de justice de
grenoble l'ancien maire de nice a
d'abord été présentée à daniel pharr vue
président de chambre d'accusation de la
cour d'appel
à l'issue d'une audition de deux heures
et demie il a été mise en examen pour
abus de confiance et placé en détention
provisoire
cette comparution a porté sur la sphère
nice opéra ou jacques médecin est
soupçonné d'avoir détourné plusieurs
millions de francs à 10h45 c'est au tour
du duo jean paul renard doyen des juges
d'instruction de nice doit faire son
entrée au palais en compagnie du
substitut du procureur et de sa
greffière
ce juge neil soit est venu signifier à
chaque médecin sa mise en examen pour
recel d'abus de biens sociaux et pour
corruption passive dans la sphère des
pots-de-vin de la crs à la sortie de ces
deux auditions son avocat s'est montré
très laconique
nous visons en examen ce que je peux
vous dire vous le savez très bien on
verra mais vous a trait à fond l'ex
maire de nice est parti du palais de
justice comme il était venu
ce va et vient se poursuivra la semaine
prochaine grenoble qui vit une fin de
semaine tumultueuse depuis un peu plus
d'une heure le conseil municipal ai
réunis c'est la première fois depuis
l'incarcération d'alain carignon qui du
fond de sa prison s'est officiellement
porté candidat pour les prochaines
municipales
des centaines d'opposants au maire de
grenoble sont rassemblés devant la
mairie
thierry kurt et et emmanuel bex sur
place on s'attendait à une journée
capitale pour l'avenir politique d'alain
carignon
et c'est d'ailleurs lui qui donnait le
ton très tôt ce matin il a annoncé sa
candidature aux prochaines municipales
par l'intermédiaire du dauphiné libéré
et son premier adjoint qui l'a
rencontrée hier ajoutait il m'a précisé
du frais d'un candidat et il a présidé
un poids supplémentaire qu'ils ont
grosso modo avec la même équipe car le
conseil municipal de ce soir est le
premier depuis qu'alain carignon et en
pouvant il y avait donc foule
cette candidature veut rappeler à une
solidarité obligé les élus de son équipe
la séance prévue à 18h et très organisée
une centaine de personnes attendaient 15
heures l'ouverture de la salle pour
occuper les 80 places disponibles pour
le public
j'estime comme à présent est que notre
présence est indispensable pour soutenir
le conseil municipal pour passant par le
médecin était réunion pourquoi ça alors
accrue au point de vue corruption
l'enrichissement et tous et lorsque vers
17 heures les sympathisants de
l'opposition arrive il ne peut compter
dans la salle du conseil
à l'intérieur l'ambiance est très tendue
la première délibération est demandée
par l'opposition
elle souhaite que la ville de grenoble
porte le plein pour son maire en se
portant partie civile
proposition rejetée par la majorité
municipale alain carignon depuis sa
prison reste le patron mais pour combien
de temps autres acteurs de cette affaire
grenobloise l'avocat jean louis dutaret
ancien pdg de la sofirad lui aussi en
prison il a reconnu aujourd'hui devant
le juge d'instruction qu'il avait bien
participé il y a 6 ans à un déjeuner au
cours duquel alain carignon et le pdg de
la lyonnaise des eaux monsieur mono
aurait conclu un pacte de corruption
en échange donc de l'attribution du
marché des eaux de la ville à la
lyonnaise des eaux à la rubrique
corruption dernier élément ce soir la
démission du pdg de la cogedim michel
maurer officiellement pour raisons de
santé
c'est une première jamais un chef
d'entreprise impliqué dans l'une des
récentes affaires judiciaires n'avaient
démissionner léo lamberton comment ça
s'est passé
c'est normalement annoncer sa démission
au monsieur monsieur moratti a annoncé
sa démission
ils sont restés particulièrement discret
les membres du conseil d'administration
de la cogedim
pourtant le pdg de la société vient de
leur annoncer sa démission
officiellement pour raisons de santé
pendant trente ans michèle morère fut
une figure respectée de l'immobilier est
depuis quatre ans il est aussi un patron
que les affaires judiciaires ont
rattrapé fondateur de la cogedim filiale
de paribas michel moser s'est illustré
comme le promoteur des quartiers chics
le spécialiste des bureaux grand
standing l'inventeur des résidences pour
personnes âgées
créé en 1990 son nom apparaît dans les
chroniques judiciaires
michel moere est condamné à deux ans de
prison avec sursis et à un million de
francs d'amendé dans le cadre d'une
vaste affaire de fausses factures en ile
de france
cette année il se retrouve impliqué par
le conseiller van ruymbeke dans la
sphère du financement du parti
républicain et le versement de
commissions occultes pour l'obtention de
permis de construire à massy incarcéré
pendant 24 jours
michèle morère a été remis en liberté le
27 octobre dernier
de tout temps il a clamé son innocence
mais aujourd'hui à 64 ans il se dit
fatigué physiquement et moralement par
ces efl en quittant ses fonctions de pdg
ou deviendra si le premier patron que
les affaires judiciaires constat
démissionner
retour maintenant à l'actualité
internationale avec une nouvelle étape
franchie dans la folie meurtrière qui
secoue la bosnie les serbes ont lâché
des bombes au napalm sur l'enclavé
musulmane de biatch gilles rabin
la dernière fois qu'on avait utilisé du
napalm dans une guerre c'était au
vietnam
les serbes l'ont fait ce matin sur
l'enclavé de biatch et casques bleus
viennent de confirmer cette double
violation de ce que militaires et
diplomates appellent les lois de la
guerre visage du napalm est prohibé
depuis le vietnam justement le survol de
biya qui est interdit par une résolution
de l'onu
habillage comme à sarajevo la nuit
toutes les nuits on peut voir sa mort
arriver les armes lourdes n'auront pas
été interdite longtemps autour et
capitale bosniaque
assiégés et 1,6 et être assiégé c'est
seul à tenter de passer tout faisait
peint toutes les nu à travers les lignes
ennemies sur l'unique voie d'accès la
piste du mont igman dans sarajevo
on est plus en sécurité nulle part les
offensives bosniaques lancé pour tenter
de desserrer les sièges du pliage de
sarajevo se soldent par des contre
offensives serbe meurtrière l'europe
condamne offensives et contre-offensives
d'une même voix et mais assiégée et
assiégeant sur le même pied depuis la
semaine dernière les états unis refusent
cette eau logique et reconnaissent aux
assiégés le droit d'essayer de briser le
siège
en attendant les enfants meurent
toujours dans sarajevo
il s'appelait nermine il avait 7 ans il
a été tué d'une seule balle dans la tête
par un tireur embusqué serbe un
combattant ce drame bosniaque qui s'est
naturellement retrouvé au centre des
discussions franco britannique
aujourd'hui à chartres la france et la
grande-bretagne sont sur la même ligne
et s'oppose à la décision américaine de
lever partiellement l'embargo sur les
armes à chartres pour ce sommet philippe
harrouard et gérard dériot chartres sous
la pluie
atmosphère bon enfant étonnement même
lorsque le god save the queen est joué
par erreur à la place de la marseillaise
mais c'est l'entente cordiale non
edouard balladur prend un bain de foule
mouillé une rue plus loin françois
mitterrand avec des roses en plus la
municipalité de chars et sociales et on
en arrive à l'ordre du jour sur le
dossier de la défense et de la sécurité
ça marche entre paris et londres la
preuve les deux pays ont créé un groupe
franco britannique pour coordonner des
opérations aériennes ponctuèrent à
l'étude également la construction d'un
avion européen de transport de troupes
même longueur d'onde encore sur la
bosnie la france et la grande bretagne
qui ont des casques bleus sur
l'éclairage travail en commun un
règlement de paix
d'où leurs regrets et leur inquiétude
face à la décision américaine de ne plus
contrôler l'embargo sur les armes en
bosnie danger dit le président
mitterrand un tour nouveau été pris qui
apparaît comme excessivement brutale
qu'ils ont un canton mes virages
dangereux dangereux mais ce n'est pas un
virage décidé de façon collective reste
l'europe et son avenir là les points de
vue sont beaucoup moins convergent les
on en reparlera lors de la réunion des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens
début décembre à essen en allemagne
l'actualité sociale avec le conflit
d'alstom à belfort les grévistes
continuent d'occuper les usines ils ont
également bloqué l'express
paris july actions mais aussi
négociations dans la plus grande
discrétion pour tenter de trouver un
accord avant que l'ordre d'évacuer les
bâtiments ne soit donnée une
manifestation est prévue demain après
midi à ben les socialistes auraient pu
faire des conflits sociaux le thème de
leur congrès qui vient de s'ouvrir
seulement voilà l'échéance
présidentielle est proche et pendant
trois jours l'ombre de jacques delors
planera sur le pas de calais demain
françois mitterrand sera à liévin et les
socialistes n'attendent que lui sur
roland sicard et eric de la guerre
finalement jacques delors ne sera pas
totalement absent du congrès les
militants ne verront pas en chair et en
os comme il l'aurait voulu mais ils
pourront au moins acheter son livre pour
se consoler seulement à vrai dire la
plupart des militants avaient
aujourd'hui la tête ailleurs car leur
surprise ils l'auront demain avec le
passage de françois mitterrand à liévin
et ça pour un socialiste c'est quelque
chose je crois j'ai les larmes aux yeux
parce que ce monsieur je dois je dois
tout le respect qui est super et
magnifique pour moi mais ces différences
dans l'histoire ce plus grande qu'on a
vu à voir d'emporter socialiste après on
sait ce qu'on va perdre c'est parce
qu'on va récupérer automatiquement
et justement une image en chassant une
autre les dirigeants eux doivent aussi
penser aux prochaines échéances et à
dire à la présidentielle comme au ps
diddy présidentielle dit jacques delors
beaucoup s'interrogent pourquoi le
patron de la commission européenne n'a
t-il pas fait le déplacement
entre ceux qui le soutiennent et ceux
qui le soutiennent - les avis divergent
j'aurais souhaité qu'il soit là oui je
pense que ça aurait été plus normal pour
un militant socialiste d'être avec son
parti c'est une prise de distance
physique qui vient après une prise de
distance politique on va pas refaire le
congrès là dessus les voilà il parlera
en décembre à bien nous occupons nous de
nos affaires pourraient quand même
je vous dise d'abord silva et c'est pas
c'est pas un petit détail indice avait
fait son choix il aurait été le bienvenu
et ont été applaudis par trou
congressistes bon l'a pas fait encore
dans ces conditions et ne vient pas
c'est tout à fait normal
on peut le regretter sur le plan de
l'amitié de la chaleur humaine on peut
le comprendre en termes d'analysé
politique et pour henri emmanuelli toute
la difficulté est là comme on mettre
d'accord les socialistes sur le cas de
l'or car si le congrès par des dérapages
amené le patron de la commission
européenne déjà hésitant à renoncer le
parti risquerait d'aller droit à la
déroute françois mitterrand aura sans
doute demain quelques conseils à donner
les socialistes que le premier ministre
edouard balladur a vivement attaqué cet
après midi au cours d'une rencontre avec
des élus dans la région de chartres
après le sommet franco-britannique
écouter l'idéologie socialiste a fait
son temps et personne n'y croit plus
puis ce que j'observe eux mêmes que ceux
qui voudrait s'inspirer ou plutôt se
présentait comme émanant de cette
inspiration ni ont pu recours et d'autre
part ne sont plus non plus dans les
années 80 où l'on pensait que la liberté
débridée sans frein et sans règles
résoudrait tous les problèmes de la
société
nous devons nous tenir également éloigné
du socialisme et de népotisme d'un côté
et de l'ultra libéralisme de l'autre
pendant ce temps là le débat d'idées
s'amorce on l'a suffisamment attendu
pour qu'il soit utile aujourd'hui d'en
parler en 48 heures dans le figaro
jacques chirac a fixé ses priorités
véronique saint-aulaye si jacques chirac
a finalement choisi de se lancer plus
tôt que prévu dans la campagne
présidentielle
c'est pour pouvoir proposer sans plus
attendre et sans faux semblants à tous
les français les perspectives et les
choix nécessaires selon lui à une france
qu'il décrit comme
démotivée alors cette semaine avec deux
longue interview au figaro et à la
tribune le candidat chirac ouvre son
agenda de réformes celle qu'il voudrait
engager dans les six mois qui suivront
l'élection présidentielle dans la lutte
contre le chômage pas de méthode
révolutionnaire
jacques chirac pour le développement des
emplois de service et de proximité
le soutien aux pme et le financement par
l'impôt des dépenses sociales qui relève
de la solidarité nationale
jacques chirac montrent en revanche au
créneau de l'école il est favorable à la
semaine de cinq jours et à l'ouverture
de l'école et de l'université aux
entreprises le tout après une grande
consultation nationale
de quoi provoquer des remous dans le
corps professoral et bouche aussi d'une
nouvelle politique de la ville et du
logement avec des allègements de charges
pour inciter artisans commerçants et pme
à s'installer dans des quartiers
difficiles
une façon selon jacques chirac de
recréer un nouvel équilibre social avec
aussi des incitations fiscales
d'accession à la propriété notamment
pour les plus bas salaires
autant de propositions en forme
d'engagement autant de sons aussi auprès
de le plu au public concernant
l'éducation une réaction ce soir celle
du ministre concerné françois bayrou qui
considère qu'un référendum pour modifier
le système éducatif comme le propose la
chirac
c'est le type même de la fausse bonne
idée un bon chiffre
c'est presque devenu une habitude le
commerce extérieur de la france a dégagé
en septembre un excédent de 9,18
milliards de francs
le commerce extérieur français
excédentaire depuis le début de l'année
si votre week-end des parisiens et que
vous rêvez de montagne ne cherchez plus
le parc des princes temple du football
devient pour deux jours une piste de ski
la neige est arrivée dans l'après midi
thierry clopeau c'était hier au col du
petit saint bernard à 2500 mètres
d'altitude en express 7 et pelleteuses
ont extrait mille tonnes de neige
immaculée de la montagne à coups de
canon ensuite toute la poudreuse a été
chargé dans 30 semi remorque
direction la capitale
24 heures plus tard c'est le
périphérique la traversée de paris la
porte de saint cloud et en bon savoyard
la fierté d'avoir acheminé le blanc
manteau va la ramener la neige sur place
et qu'ils auront plaisirs de la montagne
j'espère qu'ils se rendront dans les
stations d'arraisonnement bien besoin
en tout il faut faire vite car à 14
degrés de température à l'extérieur cela
fond comme neige sous la pluie la fraise
du parc des princes doit donc mettre les
bouchées doubles pour recouvrir cette
piste de 120 mètres de long de 30 mètres
de large avec une déclinaison au sommet
de 30 % la vapeur mal pendant que
certains bugs
d'autres plus petits s'initient au ski
de fond
moustapha n'a pas vraiment le pied
skieurs fred beauchêne l'organisateur
lui est devenu un père noël moderne et
n'est pas conforme avait parlé de la
planche à voile à paris avec des
ventilateurs que l'on me prenait pour un
cinglé je crois que là quelque part
bon les idées sur la pole mais elles
sont réalisées et puis ses 10 ans
d'expérience qui nous permette à la fois
de rêver mais de créer ce qui est
fonctionnel avec une équipe de garçons
solide
ce sont maintenant 300 bénévoles venus
de savoie et de haute-savoie qui vont
préparer cette piste de 120 m toute la
nuit et puis demain matin normalement si
tout se passe bien à partir de 10h et
bien tous les franciliens pourront venir
ce qui est s'essayer sur les bosses et
sur le sort fait puis le soir à partir
de 20 heures ce sera le grand show avec
la présence d' edgar grospiron est loin
de la neige la douce odeur du rhum
commence à taquiner les papilles de
laurent bourgnon largement en tête de la
traversée de l'atlantique en solitaire
laurent bourgnon qui doit arriver à
pointe-à-pitre en guadeloupe dimanche
avant 22h10 pour établir un nouveau
record de l'épreuve
sur place notre envoyé spécial
christophe du chien si tout va bien pour
lui laurent bourgnon sera le premier des
skippers de la route du rhum à être en
vacances des vacances au soleil
bourgnon a retrouvé du vent son trimaran
avance à une vitesse raisonnable de quoi
faire au direct pointe à pitre
pour l'instant ça va dans les heures qui
viennent ça devrait aller mieux encore
après treize jours de mer depuis le
temps qu'il fait la course en tête
bourgnon et pressé d'arriver arriver oui
mais pas n'importe quel moment
bourgnon m le ti punch c'est une chose
apparemment paul vatine normand n'aime
pas que le cidre ces dernières heures
vatine et son trimaran où le vent fou un
vent plus favorable que celui bourgnon
qui les propulse à une vitesse moyenne
légèrement supérieure à 20 noeuds mais
vatine possède toujours deux cents
milles de retard sur le leader avant
l'arrivée à pointe-à-pitre la route du
rhum nous offre un double duel au soleil
bourgnon vatine pour les multicoques
parliez gauthier pour les monocoques
pour parier ça va moins fort yves
parlier n'a pas de routes d'eure son
programme informatique est tombé en
panne et le prix donc d'informations
météo
du coup parler s'est retrouvé dans une
zone de calme plat si donc son
poursuivant alain gautier le dernier
vainqueur du vendée globe challenge qui
se refait une santé en 24 heures cottier
a réussi à combler la moitié de son
retard
gauthier parliez va-t-il bourgnon ces
quatre hommes sur la mer se bat pour une
place au soleil
en football après la piètre prestation
de l'équipe de france en pologne les
dirigeants et notamment le président de
la ligue noël le graet affirme qu'il ya
un réel problème
eric cantona et ils se demandent s'ils
doivent le garder dans l'équipe tandis
que jean pierre papin qui ne jouait pas
avec l'équipe de france en pologne s'est
cassé la main gauche à l'entraînement
aujourd'hui avec le bayern de munich une
qui respire la santé c'est mary pierce
notre finaliste de roland garros elle
s'est qualifiée la nuit dernière pour
les demi finales du masters féminin
c'était à new york
laurent frédéric bollée il y a deux
jours elle était malade mais d'hier si
bien steffi graf qui est sortis écoeurés
du coup
mary pierce avait échangé la fièvre de
la grippe contre la fièvre du jeudi soir
la fièvre de la victoire quarts de
finale du masters spears se retrouvent
donc graff numéro un mondial c'est la
revanche de la demi finale de roland
garros
et là encore pierce sort le grand jeu le
madison square garden de new york
chavigny et graff tempête
certes l'allemande s'est arrêté trois
semaines avant de revenir à la
compétition pour ce master il n'empêche
la balle de match et symbolique
graff visé ligne mais pierce tient bon
et celle allemande qui la première va
craquer
score finale 6/4 6/4 mary pierce cros
route vers son premier très grand titre
voilà et après le sport place à la
musique avec notre invité un invité
prestigieux sting rebond soir avec un la
sortie d'un album qui retrace dix ans de
carrière en solo cela s'appelle fields
of gold et dans cet album de chansons
inédites parmi ces deux chansons
la première s'appelle when we dance et
nous regardons un extrait du clip vidéo
ça
on
yum
pas sûr
com
voilà vous écoutiez attentivement est-ce
que ça n'est pas un peu frustrant de
résumer dix années de carrière en un
seul disque non pas du tout c'est très
excitant que de pouvoir le faire mais
sun
semblait pas être dix ans ça semble être
5 3 ç'a passé très très vite et beaucoup
de chansons et je suis très content du
disque comment les avez vous choisi
précisément la sélection les chansons
sont choisis d'elle-même comme les
enfants sont très précoces
c'est très facile alors dix ans une
carrière en solo quand vous regardez ce
que vous aviez fait avant la période
avec le groupe police que beaucoup de
gens ont adoré aussi qu'est ce que vous
préférez la carrière solo ou police non
c'est beaucoup plus agréable d'être seul
parce qu'on n'a pas se disputer sans
arrêt ya passage de comités pour prendre
des décisions il ya plus de liberté non
je suis beaucoup plus heureux maintenant
j'ai lu quelque part que vous disiez je
préfère le sting qui a 40 ans que le
sting qui avait 25 30 ans pourquoi c'est
vrai d'abord et pourquoi oui je crois
que suis beaucoup plus calme pour pu
reposer
je supplie modeste je suis plus beaux
noms je me sens plus à l'aise
quarante ans c'est mieux la vie
s'améliore quand on a eu le touch succès
que vous avez eu ces dernières années
que ce soit avec le groupe police ou ou
vous même tout seul et ce qu'on est
encore angoissé à la sortie d'un disque
ou pour vous c'est finalement pas très
important l'important ça ça reste la
musique
non je crois que j'essaie de faire le
meilleur disque possible sortir si ça
marche tant mieux sinon ça fait rien on
a l'impression que vous avez énormément
de recul par rapport à votre métier par
rapport à votre profession
oui je crois qu'il est bon en effet de
faire le point sur tous a à mon âge de
se demander si on a fait quelque chose
d'utile
il est bon en effet de faire le bilan de
sa vie dans le jeu fait toujours donc
sous c'est dans ce sens-là oms estime
que vous vous êtes beaucoup engagé pour
pour ceux des causes qu'elles soient
humanitaires on se rappelle de tout ce
que vous avez fait pour la forêt
amazonienne
qu'est ce qui vous paraît aujourd'hui le
plus important et quels sont les
engagements vous
privilégiez bien je suis toujours très
impliqué dans la forêt des mânes
d'amazonie importants partis moments où
on s'engage en faveur d'une cause de
continuer à accompagner cette cause et
de ne pas y renoncer pendant sept ans
donc je suis impliqué en amazonie nous
avons livré de nombreux combats et la
guerre continue vous allez rechanter en
france bientôt beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de gens se posent la question
il espère à la télévision demain soir
oui je ne sais plus comment s'appelle
l'émission c'est sur notre chaîne si
c'est pas sur notre chaîne ça n'a aucune
importance et des concerts
éventuellement en avant dans les
prochaines merci beaucoup pour votre
visite je rappelle donc le titre de
votre album qui sort
actuellement ça s'appelle fields of gold
donc un retour sur dix années de
carrière en solo merci beaucoup d'être
d'être venu sur le plateau ce soir
merci merci pour terminer le journal et
pour vous permettre de savourer le
nouveau feuilleton télévisé du vendredi
soir nicolas winckler a suivi les traces
et l'imagination de didier daeninckx de
sa plume et nenova tchèque détective
privé un homme de caractère regardé les
six juges étaient comme les femmes elles
ne lui résistait jamais très longtemps
il savait que la meilleure façon de
violer l'intimité d'un auteur c'était de
pénétrer chez lui par surprise et par
effraction ce qu'ils étaient venus
chercher ici ils ne le savaient pas
lui-même peut-être juste ce qu'il
fallait d'un 10 pour comprendre à qui il
avait affaire derrière la porte
ça se précise
des bouquins couverture jaune et noir
ambiance polar c'est ici qu'ils
travaillent les livres et les coupures
de journaux jeter au hasard sur son
bureau révèle un goût de l'exactitude et
de la précision
il déroule le fil de ses intrigues entre
paris anvers lisbonne barcelone prague
ou berlin cela fait près de vingt ans
qu'il passe le plus clair de son temps à
skis comme ça derrière son bureau à
pianoter ses mains la ont fait naître
plus de 23 vraiment un nouvel didier
daeninckx est l'un des grands du roman
policier c'est lui le papa de
l'inspecteur de votre chèque une chambre
avec ce soit les services secrets
qu'elle supprimait de là pourquoi
exactement ce qu'on voudra savoir
comment on n'a pas besoin d'en savoir
plus
pardon je me suis tombé sur son conclut
magouillait ne sais quoi avec des
écoutes industriels il aurait pas lui
était version moi j'ai pas de version
demoitie simplement qu'on avance à pas
de géant dans cette enquête et j'ai pas
envie d'abandonner maintenant cette fois
c'est une question d'éthique
c'est quelqu'un qui est entier c'est
quelqu'un qui qui a véritablement envie
de de faire tomber les masques de
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la vérité et
jusqu'au bout de la morale qu'il a dans
la tête une morale donc mais aussi une
vieille volvo une sacrée tête de mule
est toujours le même imperméable nouveau
tchèque n'est ni vraiment un héros ni
vraiment un baroudeur mais chaque pas
qu'il fait le maine un peu plus
profondément dans l'épaisseur d'une
intrigue qui se nourrit aussi bien des
grands faits de l'actualité que de la
banalité du quotidien
il était ainsi le nova tchèque des
romans et celui du petit écran
magnifiquement interprété par patrick
catalifo en est son exact reflet alors
venez sol et sans arme ou après tout si
ça vous chante en famille avec des chips
didier daeninckx nous donne rendez vous
ce soir pour une plongée en eaux
troubles
voilà nos matches et que c'est à partir
de 20h55 juste après la météo de
nathalie rihouet qui prévoit un week-end
de très doux à 22h35 que bouillon de
cultures spéciales livre après la
distribution des prix littéraires cette
semaine 23h45 taratata
à une heure du matin vous retrouverez le
dernier journal présenté ce soir par
philippe lefait et renseignements pris
sting sera dimanche dans l'émission de
jacques martin le monde et up
voilà merci beaucoup bonne soirée à
demain 13h et 20h